- Welcome to my man cave.
Come on in.
As you can see, we like to hunt
not just alligators.
Our line of work,
the wintertime we have off,
so we get to spend a lot of time
in the woods.
Dad’s always brought me up
deer hunting
in the swamps and whatnot,
and now that I’m older,
we do a lot of traveling
all over the United States
and even in Canada.
As you can see,
we’ve had some pretty good hunts
over the years.
Growing up, I always was
intrigued by taxidermy work,
and my local taxidermist
took me in under his wings
and taught me, you know,
the ins and outs of it.
I do love doing it.
I’ve done
some of the animals in here.
These deer right here on
this wall were all done by me.
We got a little mixture
of everything.
These at the top up here are
some elk that I shot in Montana.
I shot ’em
in back to back years.
It was pretty neat trying
to get them things up there,
to say the least.
Well, that duck
is up there by himself
because most of the time,
basically, all I’ll hunt
is white-tail deer.
I’ll go on a couple of duck
hunts at the end of the year.
I have a picture here
on my wall that I love,
and so I’m trying to mimic
that picture right there.
Hopefully, this year I’ll go
and shoot a few more ducks,
and then I’ll start placing ’em
in that corner
the same way that
they look in this picture.
But I’ve traveled up to Canada
and shot this real big bear.
He was just a big old bear,
first bear hunt I ever went on.
You know, deer are scored
by the inches of antlers,
and bears are scored
by the width of the skull.
Once it dries out,
it’s the width and the length
of the skull.
You definitely don’t want
this guy clamping down on you.
And, of course, our
prized possession right here
is a giant alligator
that we caught one day.
He was 12-foot-4.
He broke the line.
We had to chase him down
the river for several miles
and caught up to him.
And as I was pulling
the trigger,
the gator bumped
the end of my barrel,
and right when I pulled
the trigger, it split my barrel.
So a conversation piece,
to say the least.
As you can see right here,
I still have that tooth
from that alligator last year
that bit the other alligator
in the head and broke his tooth.
This is the old
snaggle-tooth tooth.
- Look at this.
- Oh, my God.
Oh, my God, look at that tooth!
- Just the thickness
of that tooth
just shows you the power
he must have put in
to biting that alligator
and just snap it off like that.
And, I mean, it just fit
right back in there,
so we know absolutely
that was the alligator
that killed that other one.
You know, my love for hunting
comes from my dad
and my grandpa.
It’s been passed down
for years and years.
I remember not even being able
to walk through the swamp.
My dad would carry me
on his back
and bring me rabbit hunting
with him and deer hunting.
I have my very first deer.
When I shot it,
my dad mounted it for me,
and I have it up top up there.
And then
this is my little boy’s
very first buck that he shot,
he shot last year
at six years old.
And I got to experience that
with him,
so that was pretty special
and something I’ll never forget.
We do our part
to try to help out.
We do some hunts
throughout the year
where we take kids out
that they don’t get the chance
to go out there.
We take some out
and do some hunts with ’em
just to get the experience,
you know.
We get to do it all the time
and we take it for granted.
But we’ve learned a lot
over the years
that, you know, you don’t
have to look very far
to see somebody less fortunate.
You know,
I keep a little tally
of how many deer I’ve shot
over the years,
and I’m a little over 100
right now.
You know, people say,
yeah, you shot so many,
you don’t remember anything,
and I can tell you the story
of every single deer I shot.
Dad might be
the King of the Swamp,
but they call me old
Buck Master Junior right here.